- live pictures now this is Istanbul
latest pictures from Istanbul and what
we believe is happening here our members
of this failed military coup being taken
away by the police not too sure what
building they're outside but as members
of the public there as well by the looks
of things but and those military offers
you can see them they're being held up
against a van I think they're handcuffed
as well from the looks of things but
clearly officers that have been involved
in this attempted military coup being
arrested by the police at the moment the
latest news we have is that there are
still ongoing bomb attacks according to
a senior Turkish official at around
government buildings in Ankara still
some local resistance by coup plotters
who are continuing in Istanbul and
Ankara but the senior Turkish official a
few moments ago through Reuters news
agency saying this will end soon also a
line to bring you as the authorities
have shut Istanbul zhh Bosphorus Strait
to tankers for security reasons and at
the moment we believe there is nothing
incoming or outgoing of Istanbul Airport
all those soldiers at soldiers loyal to
the government are under control at